you know one thing that uh i have to
wonder is quite difficult um as i've
experienced some something similar
myself is uh you know when you're a
creator who makes something and often
a certain type of video is it difficult
you know being stuck in the category of
the guy who talks about chris chen is
that is that something you struggle with
yes yeah
yeah
i think the word you're looking for is
pigeonholed yeah cause you know i i had
a similar thing when i started my
youtube career i was only doing a
certain type of video on a certain type
of anime
and it was like all i was known for yeah
it was what everyone referred to me as
that guy who does x video
uh at least your username isn't that
like me true yeah joey's called the
anime man so i'm kind of [ __ ]
you know
is there any
is there like a plan do you have
something you want to try and
branch out to oh yeah um actually my
channel is called geno samuel 2.1
because it's
actually originally my second channel so
my first channel is devoted to music
original and covers so that's that's
what i've been doing a lot longer than
the christian stuff
as far as japanese things go i'm i guess
i'm most most well known for doing a
cover of plastic love which kind of oh
you did i did i did got over a million
views so it's oh [ __ ] wow nice that's
that's my other thing that i'm known for
i guess nice you know for plastic and
christian
yes
two very different things
yeah
also there's the general samuel 3 which
is where i post uh documentaries that
are not about chris chan
right you did one about uh yokai right i
i do a series about yokai yeah oh cool
shortish videos about yokai and uh hope
to branch out onto other topics yeah
nice yeah did you like japanese folklore
and uh
culture and stuff like that well i
assume you are cause you're in japan
right
uh mostly focused on yokai uh other
other docs will be about different
topics yes wide range people people are
wondering why are you in japan
what brings you to japan well i've been
interested in japanese culture for a
very long time right and i started
teaching the language myself actually
when i was still in school i was
learning the
the writing systems and reading and
writing myself and then
and then i got into a course in
university which allowed me to do a year
abroad study in tokyo or in japan i
didn't know if i was going to tokyo at
that time but yeah so that allowed me to
to experience japan and then decided to
come again and work as an english
teacher
nice so yeah that's where i am now
mm-hmm
spent a year in hokkaido which was
i don't know i don't know
i mean i mean i love hokkaido yeah i've
only been on like vacations there
exactly exactly if you have to live
there for a year in a very small town of
5 000 people it's quite a different
experience which is the majority of
towns in hokkaido like most of hokkaido
is pretty desolate yeah did you you
couldn't talk to anyone actually
very little yeah my japanese skills are
not that good and um
everyone's english skills are also not
that good so
yeah so i was kind of stuck in a rut um
i was employed by the um by the city
hall or the town hall so then i would
provide english lessons to all the
schools in the town which is like three
of them so yeah preschool
primary school secondary school or the
junior high school so yeah everyone knew
me everyone looked at me everywhere i
went you're the guardian i'm the guy
junior at that point you are just the
token foreigner yeah right 5 000 yeah
yeah
yeah did you did you enjoy choosing
english
i did yeah i eventually got used to it
and i
enjoyed the
enjoy the fun of it i got used to it
it
sounds like an acquired touch yeah i
mean yeah
it was it was tough at the beginning of
course and of course hokkaido has some
very gruesome winters
uh yep actually almost died at one point
which was what what
in the winter uh yeah um i was i was at
school and we were caught by a by a
blizzard a very terrible blizzard and we
had to send all the all the kids home
and all the staff home i had to walk
home of course i didn't have a car
um
over
along along the course of the walk i got
really cold obviously and there was snow
getting in my boots and my feet were
freezing which was not good i could
barely walk because of the wind and the
snow when i got to my house i could not
open the front door because it was
frozen shut oh my god because the
because the door frame was metal
together
so i decided to go back out and go to a
convenience store to buy like an
electric lighter
in the in the van attempt to to try and
heat up the door and melt the ice along
the way i got really sleepy and i
thought oh no maybe i should i should
take a rest i really wanted to do that
but then this sounds like hypothermia
but yeah i managed to struggle my way
back home and pulled as hard as i could
because of course in japan you have to
pull the front door open not now push it
in pushing it yeah yeah which very
difficult in that sense but yeah i
actually managed to open it after a
while and heat up
crazy stuff [ __ ] did you have any
lasting side effects from that were your
feet okay i'm okay yeah
she's like yeah
i can't walk anymore
i imagine i was very close but yeah
because i i could not feel anything
there was
no sensation of like touch at all you
just wanted to teach english
i wanted to teach english right man
what's the teachings always lose his
feet
so how long been in japan for um
odd enough about four years i spent a
year as a
study abroad student in tokyo and then
one year in hokkaido tears in tokyo as a
as an english teacher for an
after-school
thing
yeah how much you have to like speak
japanese in the in your class or do you
use it for your work at all uh zero is
there japanese for us yeah really it's
an all-english environment yeah oh so
all the kids are speaking english oh
yeah oh wow is it like a cram school
kind of thing not a not a cram school
kind of like a after school almost like
a daycare so if you will so you never
get a chance to improve your japanese
right yeah
so people always people are always
online when you talk about living in
japan like oh my god you're not fluent
in like one year what the [ __ ] yeah and
it's like you don't understand when
you're here to do certain things you
don't get the opportunities that a
normal person
would would get living here
well right like we're always talking
with like english speaking stuff you
know people overseas and stuff like that
so it's very rarely that you know you
have to actually talk to japanese people
unfortunately like it sucks because you
can't just unfortunately just absorb it
via osmosis you actually have to uh get
this go out and put effort into learning
yeah you kind of have to learn it yeah
it's it's a thing which uh you do which
uh most of us hate it in school yeah as
an adult you have to choose to put time
in it because like one thing one thing
that you don't really think about is how
much time you have to put into actually
learning an activity and like you have
to put time and effort into it whereas
as an adult i don't think it's any
harder to learn a language it's just
harder to find time
to commit to it yeah like in a perfect
world i would just i would want to take
like a year off of my life just to like
fully commit to learning japanese but i
can't i have a job and i have
commitments you know
and i think as an adult that's just much
more harder to do